This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去帮助并做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供依赖与心理健康课程。获取相关能力
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
对于陪伴和支持那些面临健康和依赖问题的人至关重要。建立一份充实的职业，服务于
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
全国的法语社区。不用担心法语水平，这在LaCite是可能的。
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
今天就访问LaCite学院。这是国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。醒醒，邪恶。我是那个目睹了谋杀案的女人，
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
由Krivac和DePippo实施。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）在被判处最高刑罚后没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷》（Bone Valley）中的《魔鬼采石场》（Devil's Quarry）。快乐是必不可少的，也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您的旅程，
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
迈向更快乐的生活。《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez），
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to be Human）。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂，那就是移除一座种族主义雕像。而这里有一件事本该容易得多，那就是在原处竖立一座新的雕像。我是阿基拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《反叛精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我在看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役者的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩格（Gemma Speg），欢迎回到《你的20岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。在开始之前，我想提醒大家，这一集播客和许多其他集现在都可以在Netflix上收听了，不仅是在美国，不仅是在加拿大，还有英国、澳大利亚、德国、马来西亚、南非等等。所以，如果你喜欢在听播客的同时观看，这是你的机会。你现在，就在这一秒，只需在Netflix应用程序上搜索《你的20岁心理学》，就可以观看播客的视频版。去试试吧，看看大家都在讨论什么，我真诚地希望你喜欢它。今天，我们
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode before we get. into it, I want to remind you all that this episode of the podcast and so many others are now available on Netflix, not just in the US, not just in Canada, but in the UK, in Australia, in Germany, in Malaysia, in South Africa, just to name a few. So if you are a fan of watching a podcast as you listen to it, this is your chance. You can go and watch a video episode of the podcast right now, right this very second just by searching the psychology of your 20s on your Netflix app. Go ahead, give it a go, see what all the fuss is about, and I sincerely hope that you enjoy it. Today, we are
正在讨论我认为作为人类可以体验到的最伟大的自由之一：意识到并非每个人都会喜欢你，并且不再关心这一点。这是一件多么美好的事情。我真心认为，当你明白你不可能被所有人喜欢时，人生的第二篇章就开始了。而且，这确实是一种特权。这种情况是一种特权。像我们大多数人一样，我想我在成长过程中相信，我的幸福与喜欢我的人数之间存在直接关联。喜欢我的人越多，觉得我讨人喜欢、有趣、有意思、好相处的人越多，
talking about one of the greatest freedoms I think we can experience as human beings, realizing that not everyone will like you and simply no longer caring. What a beautiful thing. I truly think the second chapter of life begins when you come to understand that you cannot be liked by everyone. And truly, that is in fact a privilege. It is a privilege for that to be the case. Like most of us, I think I grew up believing that there was a direct correlation between my happiness and the more people who liked me. The more people who found me pleasant, enjoyable, interesting, fun to be around,
我就会越满足。所有这些强迫行为都源于那种信念系统，这些行为可能，而且绝对已经让我变得不那么快乐了。它们可能也让我成为了一个更糟糕的朋友。我认为它们让我成为了一个更糟糕的女儿、姐妹和人。你经历的生活越多，再说一次，像你们大多数人一样，我仍然处于起步阶段，但我认为慢慢地，你经历的生活越多，你就越意识到，试图强迫自己成为每个人都觉得讨人喜欢的版本，实际上会比你真正接受有些人就是不会喜欢你这件事，产生更多的不满和自我疏离。事实就是这样。所以这就是我今天想要剖析的内容。
the more fulfilled I would be. all of these like compulsions emerge from that belief system that probably and definitely have made me actually a lot less happy. They've probably also made me a worse friend. I think they've made me a worse daughter, sister, person. The more you experience life, and again, I'm still really at the beginning like most of you are, but I think slowly the more you experience life, the more you realize that trying to force yourself into a version that everyone finds pleasing is actually going to create so much more dissatisfaction and self alienation than if you just truly accepted that some people aren't going to like you. And that's just that. So that is what I want to dissect today.
为什么我们发现自己乞求他人的认可，即使我们知道这并不符合我们的最大利益；当你这样做时你失去了什么；以及当你决定，事实上是实践和排练这个原则——即并非每个人都必须喜欢你——时，你获得了什么。最后，我认为这可能意味着你做对了什么。因为这可能是一个有争议的观点，但我真心认为，被所有人喜欢的人反而很无聊。而那不是你。那绝对不是你。
Why we find ourselves begging for the approval of others, even when we know it's not in our best interests, what you lose when you do so and what you gain when you decide and in fact, practice and rehearse this idea and this principle that not everybody has to like you. And finally, I think that that probably means you're doing something, right? Because this might be a controversial take, but I genuinely think that people who are liked by everyone are rather boring. And that is not you. That is certainly not you.
所以，如果你能拥抱“不被喜欢”的力量，以及这对你的身份意味着什么，对你的性格说明了什么，我认为你将成为一个更有趣、更有趣、更精彩的人。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容，废话少说，让我们开始吧。首先，从一个非常简单的原则和一个非常简单的理解开始：为什么当我们知道这实际上可能不会发生时，我们仍然感到需要被绝对所有人深深地喜欢？最简单的解释是，我们在群体中总是最安全的。我知道这个解释已经被说了无数遍了，但当我们能够依赖
So if you can embrace the power of being disliked and what that means for your identity and what that says about your character, I think that you will become a much more interesting fun and wonderful human being. So that is what we are going to discuss today without further ado. Let's get into it. So to begin with a very simple principle and a very simple understanding, why do we feel the need to be liked so deeply by absolutely everyone when we know that that is in fact probably not going to happen? The most simple explanation is that we are and have always been safest in a group. I know that this explanation has been done a million times over, but when we can rely upon
周围的人来支持我们的个人需求时，因为他们喜欢我们，因为他们视我们为他们的一员，因为存在互惠，我们就能更好地在长期生存并获得满足。有一种进化的本能驱动力让我们回归群体，无论好坏，这从一开始就植根于我们心中，因为群体，群体代表了一个我们可以预测的强大系统，一个我们感到最不容易受到威胁的系统，以及独自面对事情在情感、身体和心理上的危险。我们作为人类的许多行为都是由我们想要依附和被喜欢的欲望所决定的。任何说不是这样的人，任何说他们不在乎的人，谁说，
others around us to support our individual needs, because they like us, because they see us as one of them, because there is reciprocity, we are better primed to survive in the long run and to be fulfilled. There is this evolutionary instinctual drive to return back to the herd for better and for worse, and that has been embedded in us since the very beginning, because the herd, the herd represents a strong system that we can predict, a system where we feel least susceptible to threats, and also the danger emotionally, physically, mentally, of having to go at things alone. So much of our behavior as humans is determined by our desire to attach and our desire to be liked. And anybody who says otherwise, anybody who says they don't care, who says,
当他们完全不受他人意见影响时，他们是在撒谎，因为那样感觉就像是在否认你的人性本质以及作为人的意义。我们知道这是一种基本的驱动力。我们知道被喜欢的欲望是一种基本的驱动力，因为当它没有得到满足时，我们能感觉到。具体来说，当我们感到不被接受时，我们会感到孤独。孤独与饥饿、口渴和疲倦等事物并列。它是一种情绪，是的，但它，它，它，它，它，它也是一种生物学信号，表明我们功能所需的东西，在这种情况下是社会认可，没有得到满足。我相信你们都听说过这个，但孤独、拒绝、不被社会接纳，会以几乎与真实的身体、有形疼痛相同的方式影响你的身体。
as they are completely unaffected by others' opinions are lying, because to feel that way would be to deny the very nature of your humanity and what it means to be human. We know this is a fundamental drive. We know the desire to be liked as a fundamental drive, because we feel it when it's not met. Specifically, when we don't feel accepted, we feel lonely. And loneliness sits parallel to things like hunger and thirst and tiredness. It is an emotion, yes, but it is, it is. It is, it. It is, it. It is, is also a biological sign that something we need for functioning, in this case, social acceptance, is not being met. I'm sure you've all heard this before, but loneliness, rejection, not feeling socially included, affects your body in ways, in almost identical ways to true physical, tangible pain.
我们必须记住，疼痛不是在身体中感受到的，而是在大脑中感受到的。当你擦伤膝盖时，那个说“哎哟，好痛，处理一下”的部分实际上并不是你的膝盖。是你的大脑在解释和感受来自膝盖神经的信号。大脑中发生的那些相同的内部系统同样会被孤独等事物激活，这意味着不被喜欢实际上等同于身体受伤。你的大脑无法分辨区别。你所拥有的感觉，它们并不夸张。
We have to remember, pain is not felt in the body it is felt in the mind. When you scrape your knee, the part of you that goes, ouch, that hurts, let's deal with that, is not actually your knee. It is your brain that's interpreting and feeling the sensation that is arriving from the neurons in your knee. Those same internal systems that are happening in your mind are equally activated by things like loneliness, meaning that not feeling liked is literally the equivalent of being physically wounded. Your brain cannot tell the difference. The feelings you are having, they're not dramatic.
被所有人喜欢的欲望并不夸张。它有科学支持。这就是为什么我们发展出讨好他人的倾向，以及为什么我们试图在我们遇到的每个人或我们接触的每个人面前伪装自己。我们本质上是在试图确保无论如何，我们都不会被遗弃在寒冷中。如果我们为每个人而活，
The desire to be liked for everybody is not dramatic. It is backed by science. This is why we develop people-pleasing tendencies and why we try and chameleon ourselves for everyone we meet or everybody we engage with. We are essentially trying to ensure that no matter what, we won't be left out in the cold. If we are for everyone,
将永远不会，将不会缺少喜欢我们、成为我们的朋友、支持我们、想到我们的人。这感觉就像保险，因为如果我们目前结盟的人突然抛弃我们，我们被所有人喜欢的事实，我们有这些后备力量的事实，感觉很重要，感觉很安全，并减少了我们在心理上被排斥的可能性。同样有趣的是，我们担心别人想法的倾向，也部分是因为我们实际上高估了别人对我们的关注程度。我们高估了这一点，因为更强烈地以他人的意见为中心，使我们能够再次预先应对这种深刻的
there will never be, there will be no shortage of people who will like us, who will be our friend, who will support us, who will think of us. And that feels like insurance, because if the people we are currently aligned with suddenly drop us, the fact that we are liked by everybody, the fact that we have these backups feels significant and feels safe and reduces the likelihood in our mind of being ostracized. What's also interesting is, that our tendency to worry about what other people think is also partly because we actually overestimate how much other people think about us. And we overestimate that because centering other people's opinions more strongly allows us to preempt again this deep
被拒绝的社会威胁。现在，这种认为每个人在任何时候都只在想你的现象，有一个名字，这是我们在播客中提到过的名字，它被称为“聚光灯效应”（The Spotlight Effect）。本质上，我们的思想认为有一盏巨大的灯照在我们所做的一切事情上。我们做错的每一件事，我们做对的每一件事，每一个瑕疵，我们不禁高估了自己在他人生活中的角色，并认为自己更重要。
social threat of being rejected. Now, this phenomena of believing that everybody at all times is thinking only about you, has a name, it's a name we've mentioned on the podcast before, it's called The Spotlight Effect. Essentially, our mind believes there is this big, giant light shining down on everything that we're doing. Everything that we are doing wrong, everything that we're doing right, every floor, we can't help but overvalue our role in other people's lives and think of ourselves as more significant.
你知道，我们再次想象这盏聚光灯到处跟着我们，引起对我们宁愿隐藏的一切的注意。原因在于，我们拥有这种效应的原因是，因为我们是主角，对吧？在我们自己的生活中，宇宙围绕着我们旋转。因此，当我们试图进入他人的思想来评估他们如何看待我们时，我们认为他们一定是以我们看待自己的方式看待我们，即处于一切的中心。我们所有的瑕疵都暴露无遗，我们所有的错误对他们来说都像对我们一样清晰。我们赋予了他们我们对自己所拥有的那种视角。而这显然会产生一种奇怪的恐慌。
You know, we imagine, again, this spotlight following us around everywhere, bringing attention to everything we'd rather conceal. The reason being, the reason why we have this effect, is that because we are the main character, right? In our own lives, the universe revolves around us. And therefore, when we attempt to slip into the minds of others to evaluate how they're seeing us, we think they must be seeing us as we see ourselves, which is at the center of everything. All our floors laid out, all of our mistakes clear to everyone as they are to us. We give them the sight that we have over ourselves. And this obviously creates a weird panic.
你知道，研究人员发现并检查了聚光灯效应是触发强迫性自我监控和自我审查的主要因素之一，作为对这种高度不安全感的反应，即每个人一定都知道关于我们的重大秘密，每个人一定都在想我们。研究人员揭示的另一件事是，聚光灯效应实际上只对我们自己是真实的。没有人那么关注你。有太多的研究表明，我认为大约90%的人的日常想法都是关于他们自己的。然而，理性上，我们无法看穿这一点。让我们谈谈当我们试图为每个人而活时我们失去了什么。我们已经谈到了为什么我们如此渴望进入每个人的口袋、每个人的群体或周边视野或他们的生活中。
You know, researchers have found and have examined that the spotlight effect is one of the main things that triggers obsessive self-monitoring and self-policing as a reaction to this heightened sense of insecurity that everybody must know the big secrets about us and everybody must be thinking about us. The other thing that researchers reveal is that the spotlight effect, again, is actually real only for us. Nobody is thinking about you that much. There have been so many studies that show I think it's like 90% of people's daily thoughts are about themselves. And yet rationally, we can't see through that. Let's talk about what we lose when we try to be for everyone. We've kind of spoken about why it is we are so eager to be in every single person's pocket and every single person's group or peripheral vision or in their lives.
这代价是什么？这对我们的生活、我们的注意力跨度和我们的时间有什么影响？快乐骄傲月，多伦多。骄傲是一个让你创造属于自己的空间，庆祝你存在的机会。IHeart Radio很荣幸能成为官方赞助商。多伦多骄傲节，我们不会停止。庆祝骄傲。调大爱，收听IHeart Pride Canada。
What is the cost of this? What does this do to our lives and to our attention spans and to our time? Happy Pride Month, Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor. of Pride Toronto Festival, and we won't stop. Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada.
您的24/7广播流，也是您多伦多骄傲庆祝活动所需的唯一播放列表。骄傲之所以伟大，是因为它给了很多人以前从未有过的这种可见性。多伦多，我们有很多值得庆祝的事情。快乐骄傲，IHeart Radio。在那一刻，感觉好像持续了永远。
Your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride, IHeart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever.
我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有……任何东西。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。
I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no... anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
害怕说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀了一个孩子。再糟糕不过了。我想也是。人们醒醒。我是那个目睹了谋杀案发生的人，由Crevette和DePippo实施。
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo.
安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。我没有罪。我会把这件事带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼采石场》。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaV for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》的主持人。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the Devil's Quarry on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaV for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby.
我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。
Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这对我来说也是惊喜的一部分，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都视我为特别的，一个足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常平凡到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈，在那里
It is part of the surprise to me because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me a special. a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where
脆弱性显露出来。阴谋论被摆上桌面，目标和教训被分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等我，我在这里是为了让我能够连接。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与IHeart Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是一个卡拉克。哇。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。
vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm here to put me going to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. On Javier El Chicharro-Nandes and together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
这里有一件事本不该如此复杂，那就是移除一座种族主义雕像。而这里有一件事本该容易得多，那就是在原处竖立一座新的雕像。只要美国存在种族政治，就会存在关于内战记忆的政治。为了去学校，我必须走罗伯特·李大道。去杂货店，我必须走杰斐逊·戴维斯大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却遗漏了一半的历史，你就没有尽到你的职责。我是阿基拉·休斯，《反叛精神》第二季深入探讨了这两件事。斗争、政治、获胜的人，以及我个人在肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正值得墙面空间的东西的运动。
Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Ely Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space.
我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含本质。我们包含精神。你如何代表这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，这真的正在蔓延。你会明白我的意思。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。首先，需要被所有人喜欢所带来的最大问题是，你冒着失去连贯的自我意识或任何你可能拥有的稳定核心的风险，因为你迎合了所有其他人的品味。如果我们不断地成为一个情感上的、社会上的、
We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. Firstly, the biggest thing that comes from needing to be liked by everybody is that you risk losing a coherent sense of self or any stable core that you may have because you've panned it to everybody else's tastes. If we are constantly becoming an emotional, social,
身体上的自我版本，而那并不是真正的我们，只是为了适应我们认为别人会喜欢的样子，如果那个东西在不断变化，我们怎么知道我们到底是谁？成为个体需要有强烈的偏好，对吧？它要求你真正喜欢某些事物，但也真正讨厌其他事物。它要求你真正关心某些事件或情况，而不那么关心其他事情。这意味着由于这些偏好和激情，你自然会与某些仅仅是不以同样方式思考的人结盟或不结盟。对于某些人来说，这种不结盟可能会滋生厌恶。那种厌恶，那种对立，通常是一件好事。这表明你有足够强烈的感受，并且足够了解自己，让一个同样有强烈感受的人能够识别出你思考得很强烈，并且不同意你的观点。那种分歧，甚至可能是那种厌恶，如果它达到了那个程度，有时只能发生，因为你参与其中，并且因为你拥有激情。如果你失去了那种激情，是的，你可能会获得讨人喜欢，因为你
physical version of ourselves that isn't really us to fit in with what we think others will like, how do we know who we really are if that thing is constantly changing? Being individual requires having strong preferences, right? It requires you to really like some things, but also really dislike other things. It requires you to really care about certain events or situations and not care about other things as much. That means you will naturally, because of those preferences and passions, become aligned or misaligned with certain people who just simply don't think the same way as you. And for some people that misalignment can breed dislike. That dislike, that opposition is often a good thing. It is a sign that you have strong enough feelings and know yourself well enough for somebody with equally strong feelings to be able to identify that you think strongly and to not agree with you. That disagreement and maybe even that dislike if it gets to that level at times can only occur because you had some skin in the game and because you you possessed passion. If you lose that passion, yes, you may gain likeability because you're
突然间，你知道，对每个人来说都是可口的，但你也在这个过程中失去了自己，因为你什么都不代表，什么都不关心。被所有人喜欢需要一定程度的妥协和灵活性，这再次说明，只有没有稳定中心的人才能提供或做到。不要让那成为你。研究也发现，虽然如果你迎合并渴望被他们喜欢，更多的人可能会喜欢你，但他们实际的喜欢程度以及他们对你的尊重程度实际上更低。所以基本上这些研究发现的是，你可能在每个人那里都处于50%，但你从未在任何人那里处于100%。你知道，永远不会有人完全觉得，我真的很喜欢那个人，因为你太中立了，人们无法对你产生
suddenly, you know, palatable to everyone, you also lose yourself in the process because you stand for and care for nothing. Being liked by everyone requires a level of compromise and flexibility that again, only somebody who has no stable centre can offer or can do. Don't let that be you. Studies have found as well that although more people may like you, if you pander and desire to be liked by them, their actual level of like and how much they like you, and their level of respect for you is actually lower. So basically what these studies are finding is that you might sit at 50% with everyone, but you never sit at 100% with anyone. You know, there's never going to be somebody who fully is like, I really like that person because you're too neutral for people to have an
意见。当然，这肯定有例外。你知道，我们在工作中试图成为不同版本的自己，与同事建立良好的工作关系，以确保我们获得晋升，或者我们不惹恼任何人，这很自然。如果它在社交上帮助我们，或者即使我们想给他们留下深刻印象，比如在第一次约会时，与新朋友，与朋友的第一次约会或新伴侣，我们可能会努力去被喜欢。但要挑选你的人，真正挑选你的人，并调查为什么你需要变得与你原本的样子不同才能被喜欢。如果这个人最终成为你生活中不可或缺的一部分，这种伪装和这种，你知道，假装能真正持续多久，因为最终面具，
opinion about you. Of course, there's definitely exceptions to this. You know, it's only natural that we try and be a different version of ourselves at work, have a good working relationship with our colleagues to make sure that we get the promotion or like we don't ruffle any feathers. We might make the effort to like be liked by somebody if it helps us out socially or even if we want to impress them, like on a first date, with a new friend, with a friend's first date or a new partner. But pick your people, really pick your people and investigate why you feel the need to be different to who you are to be liked. And how long that masquerade and how long that, you know, pretending can actually truly last if this person ends up being integral to your life because eventually a mask,
你的面具会滑落。我认为这真的过渡到了我们被所有人喜欢时失去的第二件事，那就是我们从未真正找到属于我们的人。我们从未找到那些100%支持我们的人。强迫一个被所有人喜欢的人格意味着那些会因为你是谁而真正喜欢你的人，无法在你所覆盖的所有这些其他垃圾下面找到你。再说一次，并不是你这样做是为了操纵。也许你这样做是为了生存，或者因为你相当社交焦虑，但这仍然是一种干扰。这个虚假的你仍然在干扰。
your mask is going to slip. I think this really segues into the second thing we lose when we are liked by everybody, which is that we never actually find our people. We never find those people who are 100% for us. Forcing a persona that is liked by everyone means that the people who would genuinely like you for who you are cannot find you underneath all this other crap that you've put on top. And again, it's not that you're doing it to be manipulative. Maybe it's you're doing it to survive or because you're quite socially anxious, but it is still a distraction. This fake version of you is still distracting.
你变得不那么诚实，不那么自然，不那么像你，因此你实际上并没有得到那些深刻而有意义的关系作为回报。2004年的一项研究表明，特别是在浪漫关系的背景下，人们知道你何时是不真实的。它成为了亲密的障碍，因为真正的亲密，我们知道这一点，需要
You become less honest, less natural, less you, and therefore you aren't actually rewarded with those deep and meaningful relationships. There was a study from 2004 that showed that in the context of romantic relationships, especially, people know when you are being inauthentic. And it becomes a barrier for closeness because true intimacy, we know this, requires
脆弱性，而核心基础，你能够脆弱的唯一方式是如果你是真实的，否则你的脆弱性就无处可取。我想我们都知道这一点，但你越是为认可而奔波，你就越不自在，别人和你在一起也就越不自在，因为他们能感觉到紧张，他们能感觉到你说话的方式背后有什么不真实的东西。他们可能会注意到你在不同的朋友面前自相矛盾，他们甚至可能会注意到你在撒谎。人们，当你，当某人，你让某人感到被操纵，或者好像他们被欺骗了，他们不想成为，他们不想成为你的朋友，他们不想成为你的朋友，他们不想约会
vulnerability and the core foundation, the only way that you can be vulnerable is if you are authentic, otherwise your vulnerability has nothing to draw from. I think we all know this, but the more you hustle for approval, the less at ease you are with yourself and the less at ease other people will be with you because they can sense the tension, they can sense that something untrue is behind the way you speak. They might notice you contradicting yourself in front of a different friend, they might even notice you lying. People, when you, when somebody, you make somebody feel manipulated or as if they're being tricked, they don't want to be, they don't want to be your friend, they don't want to be your friend, they don't want to date
你。因此，那些真正适合我们的友谊，我们无法获得，而我们剩下的友谊，通常是与那些可能正在对我们做同样事情的人，或者他们匹配了我们为那一个特定的人创造并用纸糊出来的特定版本的我们，这意味着你最终会和那些你可能甚至不喜欢，实际上在有机层面上没有任何共同点的人在一起。而这本身就会变得非常无聊和令人疲惫。再说一次，我不想告诉你不要出去努力交朋友，但要检查为什么我们经常最不喜欢，或者对我们表现出最多蔑视或厌倦的人，在某种程度上似乎成为了我们最想给他们留下深刻印象的人。
you. And so the friendships that would actually suit us, we don't get access to, and the friendships that we are left with, often with people who are probably doing the exact same thing to us, or they match a specific version of us that we have created and paper mashade for that one specific person, meaning you end up with people that you may not even like and actually have nothing organically in common with. And that in itself can get so boring and tiring. Again, I don't want to tell you to not go out there and make an effort to make friends, but examine why it is that the people we often like the least or who show the most disdain or boredom with us, in some ways seemingly become those we try to impress the most.
比如，为什么会发生这种情况？我不知道你是否注意到了这一点。这是一个真正的现象。他们持有的排他性，我们觉得需要从他们那里获得的认可变得令人陶醉，心理上令人陶醉，它变成了像奖品一样的东西。我们如此专注于此，以至于我们忘记了外面有人会爱我们，无论我们是谁，或者我们对他们有什么价值。这个现象或那种刻板印象的最好例子是，
Like, why does that happen? I don't know if you've noticed this. It's a real phenomenon. The exclusivity they hold, the approval we feel the need to gain from them becomes intoxicating, psychologically intoxicating, and it becomes this like prize. We're so fixated on that we forget that there are people out there who would love us regardless of who we are or what value we had to them. The best example of this phenomenon or like that stereotype is,
就像内群体或核心圈子，比如在高中。我觉得每一所学校都有一个。通常，让他们看起来如此受欢迎，坦率地说强大，以及让我们想成为他们的原因，很大程度上是因为他们可以选择谁被允许进入他们的群体，谁不被允许。他们非常无意识地利用了稀缺性的心理力量。而且他们的认可和属于他们的群体并不适合所有人。他们字面上，和这些人做朋友之所以如此吸引人，是因为你知道不是每个人都能做到。字面上已经有这么多关于这个的论文表明排他性和这种“不是每个人都能拥有它”的感觉驱使人们做非常
is like the in-group or the in-crowd, like at high school. I feel like every single school had one. Often, much of what made them seem so popular and quite frankly powerful and what made us want to be them is the fact that they got to choose who was and wasn't allowed into their group. They leverage very much unconsciously the psychological power of scarcity. And the fact that their approval and belonging to their group is not, not for everyone. They literally, the reason being friends with these people is so attractive is because you know that not everybody can do it. Literally there have been so many papers on this that show exclusivity and this not everyone can have it feeling drive people to do very
不理智的事情。这主要是在经济背景下被检查的。所以想想比如爱马仕包，想想奢侈品，想想流行产品，想想比如鲁布托（Laboubos）是稀缺性如何驱使人们做不理智事情的一个很好的例子。它也适用于人际关系。它也适用于我们的社交生活。你知道，与此同时，再次使用那个高中的例子，我也敢打赌，你年纪越大，你就越意识到你今天作为一个成年人，实际上并不真的尊重那些人，
irrational things. That's been examined mostly like in an economic context. So think like Omer's bags, think luxury goods, think trending products, think like Laboubos are a great example of how scarcity drives people to do irrational things. It also applies to relationships. It also applies to our social lives as well. You know, at the same time, just to use that high school example again, I'd also wager that the older you get, the more you realize that you actually don't really respect those people today as an adult,
像你在学校时认为的那样。而且你意识到你为了给他们留下深刻印象而可能做的尴尬事情，为了什么，为了什么原因？我记得我在大学时认识的一个家伙，无论出于什么原因，我相信他有他的理由。他可能确实有他的理由，但他不太喜欢我。他非常、非常、非常明确地表示他不是我的粉丝。这让我感到，我清楚地记得感觉就像我又回到了五岁。由于他明显的蔑视，我当时不断地试图给他留下深刻印象，试图证明，你。他应该喜欢我。
as much as you thought you did when you were at school. And you realize the embarrassing things you maybe did to impress them when, for what, for what reason? I remember there was this guy I knew at college who for whatever reason, I'm sure he had a reason. He probably did have his reasons, but he didn't like me very much. And he made it very, very, very well known that he was not a fan of me. And it made me feel, I distinctly remember feeling like I was like five years old again. And because of his obvious disdain, like I was constantly then trying to impress him, trying to like prove, you. that he should like me.
老实说，我现在回首往事，可以觉得，那让我看起来真的很可悲。但这也让我更加紧张和焦虑，这可能只会增加，我不知道，增加我原本拥有的他不喜欢的特质的严重性。这把我带到了试图被普遍喜欢的最终代价。这简直太累人了。就像，这太累人了。假装的心理代价是，如此巨大。除了你现在为了生存而正在做的所有其他事情之外，你还得监控
And honestly, I can look back at that now and be like, that made me look really pathetic. But also, it made me even more stressed and anxious, which probably only increased, I don't know, increased the severity of the traits that I possessed that he didn't like originally. This kind of brings me to the final cost of trying to be universally liked. It's just plain exhausting. Like, it's just so tiring. The psychological toll of pretending is, like, so enormous. On top of everything else that you are doing right now to just exist, you then have to monitor
比如每一个字，每一个动作，你走的每一步，这让你处于一种慢性过度警觉的状态，耗尽你的认知资源，耗尽你的精力，碎片化你的自我意识，所有这些都是为了一个可能从一开始就不喜欢你，也不欣赏你正在经历的所有心理折磨的人。你付出了代价，而他们甚至不欣赏回报。这就是当我们试图迎合那些似乎对我们有最大程度厌恶的人时，真正发生的事情。科学，研究，当然，你们知道，它支持这一点。2025年的一项研究调查了讨好他人是否与糟糕的心理健康有关。他们观察了超过2000名大学生。这些大学生被
like every word, every action, every step you take, and that puts you into a state of chronic hypervigilance, draining your cognitive resources, draining your energy, fragmenting your sense of self, all for somebody who probably doesn't even like you to begin with and doesn't appreciate any of the psychological stuff you're putting yourself through. You pay the cost and they don't even appreciate the reward. That's what's really happening when we try and cater to the people who seem to have the greatest level of dislike for us. Science, the research, of course, you guys know, it backs this up. A study from 2025 investigated whether people-pleasing is linked to poor and mental health. They looked at over 2,000 university students. These university students were
要求基本上评价如何，去某种程度上，是的，说出多少。他们可能每天经历多少寻求认可的想法、行为和情绪。然后他们还给了他们这个测试，测量了他们的个人幸福感。所以他们有多快乐，他们有多满足，他们有多平静。我觉得你们可能知道结果是什么，但结果，为了让它非常明显，显示出讨好他人的程度越高，心理健康水平就越低。实际上，孤独感越强，情绪困扰越多，那些最努力想让最多人喜欢他们的人是最孤独的。有强烈讨好他人倾向的参与者也
asked to basically rate how, to kind of, yeah, say how much. many approval-seeking thoughts, behaviors, and emotions they probably experienced on a day-to-day basis. And then they also gave them this test that measured their personal well-being. So how happy they were, how fulfilled they were, how at peace they were. I feel like you guys probably know what the results are, but the results, just to make it very obvious, showed that the higher the level of people pleasing, the lower the psychological well-being. And actually, the greater the loneliness, the more emotional distress, the people who were working the hardest to have the most people like them were the loneliest. Participants with strong people-pleasing tendencies also
总体上拥有最差的心理健康状况。显然这是一个双向关系，对吧？但它确实显示了处于不断需要被喜欢这种状态在心理上是多么有害。如果你没有时间留给自己，成为每个人的最爱是不起作用的。而且通常，我们感到如此多的怨恨、疲惫、沮丧，以至于我们甚至没有从归属感中获得好处，因为我们太紧张了。最终，你知道，你意识到这是毫无意义的，因为事实是，总会有人不喜欢你。你对此真的无能为力。你可以做世界上的一切。你可以花数百万美元在这个人身上。你可以满足他们最大的愿望。他们喜欢你的能力只是不，
had the worst mental health profiles overall. And obviously that's a bi-directional relationship, right? But it does show how psychologically harmful it is to be in the state of constantly needing to be light. Being everyone's favorite person doesn't work if you have no time for yourself. And often, we feel so much resentment, exhaustion, frustration, that we don't even get the benefit from belonging anyways because we're so stressed. And eventually, you know, you realize it's pointless because the thing is, someone is always going to dislike you. There's literally nothing you can do about it. You could do everything in the world. You could spend millions of dollars on this person. You could fulfill their greatest wishes. Their ability to like you is just not,
他们就是做不到。有一个社会框架。被称为25%法则。我的朋友萨尔（Sal）和阿尔（Al）在我与他们做现场节目时与我分享了这个。它指出，基本上无论你多么善良、迷人、有才华，25%的人永远不会被说服去喜欢你。分解基本上是这样的。有25%的人会一直喜欢你，一直喜欢你，并且永远会。他们将永远在你的团队中。25%的人可能最初会喜欢你，但可能会改变主意而不喜欢你。25%的人最初不会喜欢你，但可能会改变主意并有不同的印象。然后有那25%的人，无论你做什么，
they just can't do it. There's a social framework. that's known as the 25% rule. My friends, Sal and Al, shared this with me when I was doing a live show with them. And it states that basically no matter how kind, charming, talented you are, 25% of people will never be convinced into liking you. And the breakdown is basically like this. There are 25% of people will always like you, have always liked you and always will. They will always be in your team. 25% of people will maybe like you initially, but may change their mind and not like you. 25% of people won't like you initially, but may change their mind and have a different impression. And then there's that 25% of people who, irrespective of what you do,
出于某种原因都不会喜欢你。那25%是生活的事实。他们永远不会动摇。为了扩展这一点，斯坦福大学的管理科学教授鲍勃·萨顿（Bob Sutton）谈到了这个被称为90-10法则的东西。你应该努力让90%的人喜欢你，10%的人不喜欢。10%的人不喜欢你这一事实，用他的话来说，在他眼中，是值得庆祝的字面原因。这表明你做的事情非常正确，因为没有人会不喜欢一个骑墙派。没有人会不喜欢一个中立、无所事事且没有激情的人。他们不喜欢人。他们不喜欢那些有野心、有欲望并且把自己展现出来的人。
will not like you for whatever reason. That 25% is a fact of life. They're never going to budge. To expand on this, Bob Sutton, a professor of management science at Stanford, talks about this thing called the 90-10 rule. You should strive to have 90% of people like you and 10% of people not. The fact that 10% of people dislike you, in his words, in his eyes, is literal cause for celebration. That is a sign that you are doing something extremely right because no one dislikes somebody who is a fence sitter. Nobody dislikes somebody who is neutral, doing nothing and without passion. They dislike people. They dislike people who have ambition, desires, and who put themselves out there.
逻辑随之而来。如果没有一部分的你是在外面追求事物，没有人会不喜欢你。而且像真正投资于自己，因为其中有某种内在的东西是他们不喜欢的。对吧？太频繁了，我们对需要说服那25%，或需要说服那10%的先入为主，正如鲍勃先生对我们所说的那样，阻碍了我们。这就是他所说的。他说，如果你有100%的人喜欢你，你就没有发挥你的全部潜力。当我们接受这一点时，就像再次，这个我们从未知道存在的第二扇门被打开了。突然间，你步入了这个全新的宇宙，它在运行
Logic follows. Nobody's going to dislike you if there is not a part of you that it is out there and chasing things. And like really investing in yourself because there's something inherent in that that they dislike. Right? All too often, our preoccupation with needing to convince the 25%, or needing to convince the 10%, as Mr. Bob was saying to us, holds us back. That's what he's saying. He's saying, if you had 100% of people like you, you are not achieving your full potential. When we accept that, like again, this like second door we never knew existed is opened. And suddenly you step into this whole new universe that was running
平行于你之前所在的那个，在那里一切都容易得多。这只是容易得多，而且你可能也是一个更好、更善良、更快乐的人。那么我们如何转变到那个宇宙呢？我们如何转变到那种存在方式呢？好吧，我永远不会让你们悬着。你知道我有我的建议。你知道，我有我的小建议清单，我的心理指南，我将在这次短暂休息后提供给你们。骄傲月，多伦多。骄傲是一个让你创造属于自己的空间，庆祝你存在的机会。IHeart Radio很荣幸能成为多伦多骄傲节的官方赞助商，我们不会庆祝骄傲。调大爱，收听IHeart Pride Canada。
parallel to the one you were previously in where everything's just a lot easier. It's just a lot easier and you're probably a nicer and kinder and happier person as well. So how do we shift into that universe? How do we shift into that way of being? Well, I'm never going to leave you guys hanging. You know I have my tips. You know, I have my little list of advice, my psychological guide, which I'm going to provide to you after this short break. Pride month, Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival and we won't celebrate pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada. Your 24-7 radio stream and the only
您的24/7广播流，也是您所需的唯一播放列表
playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. Iheart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. It was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case?
多伦多骄傲游行所需的播放列表。骄傲游行之所以伟大，是因为它让一大群人获得了前所未有的关注。多伦多，我们有很多值得庆祝的事情。骄傲月快乐。IHeart Radio。那一刻，感觉时间仿佛静止了。我以为我活不成了。我当时吓坏了。那双眼睛里空洞洞的，什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。那真的把我吓坏了。那是你经手的第一个谋杀案吗？
Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo.
是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸谋杀案。这是最恶劣的案件。我想也是。人们，醒醒吧。我就是那个亲眼目睹了克雷维特和德皮波行凶的人。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most.
安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说过我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。想要收听无广告版《魔鬼的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在 Apple Podcasts 上订阅 LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》播客的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最……
most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战。“我经历过乳腺癌，后来又帮助母亲抗击乳腺癌，那比我自己患病更艰难。”很多人了解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑症毫无准备。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。这非常令人兴奋，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为足球运动员，但在那之前，我首先是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
我仍然有很多疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？有外星人吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just.
从日常琐事到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈，展现脆弱的一面。阴谋论会被摆上台面，目标和经验也会被分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。
Wait-in me, I'm going to be able to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio,
等等，我将能够……能够……能够建立联系。我是小豌豆。与 IHeart Radio 一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡，敬请关注。这真是太棒了。请在 IHeart Radio、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, And on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now.
Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如斯韦·李。“你意识到你有多传奇了吗？”“我很感激。我本该看到的，但我感觉，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。比如王子，他发行了大约 30 张专辑。我们现在才发行了大约 5 张。”
Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed whenaz's early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. Yes.
“这就是我们必须达到的速度。”“是的，那是个好态度。”你还会听到行业传奇和嘻哈先驱的故事，比如法布·五·弗雷迪。“我执导了纳斯早期的视频。”“哪一个？”“《One Love》。”“哇。”“是的。”
literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nans was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations.
“真的是在他位于皇后桥的公寓里拍摄的。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始走红。他爸爸以前住在哈莱姆区我附近。他父亲向他介绍了许多，你知道的，有意识的东西，他造就了一位年轻的天才。”无论什么时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大牌的嘉宾和最直白的对话。
Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Accepting that people don't like you is basically just accepting, I think, a much deeper truth in life, which is that you can't control everything. And you waste precious time trying, time that you could be using to do side quests to make your visions into reality, to be like, whoever the fuck you want to be. A study from 2018 showed that people who accept difficult mental experiences like these
请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听来自 Black Effect 播客网络的《Drink Champs》。接受别人不喜欢你，本质上就是接受生活中一个更深层的真理，那就是你无法控制一切。你把宝贵的时间浪费在尝试控制上，而这些时间本可以用来做些支线任务，将你的愿景变为现实，成为你想成为的任何人。2018 年的一项研究表明，那些接受这些困难心理体验的人，
ones, like that of being disliked, rejected, they actually end up achieving a greater level of psychological health, a greater level of social enlightenment. And they typically have more friends because this acceptance helps them change the narrative around why this is happening to them to be something that is more neutral. Basically, they stop searching for a personal explanation for everybody else's problem with them, and they realize that this is a universal truth of being human. Now, obviously, some of these people probably should do some digging, but we're talking about the people who are falling in that 25, 10% of just like the general populate. There's like some people who don't like them. They've tried to investigate,
比如被讨厌、被拒绝，实际上最终获得了更高水平的心理健康和更高水平的社会启蒙。他们通常有更多的朋友，因为这种接受帮助他们改变了关于为什么会发生这种情况的叙述，使其变得更加中立。基本上，他们不再为别人对他们的问题寻找个人解释，而是意识到这是身为人类的普遍真理。当然，有些人可能确实需要反思一下，但我们谈论的是那些处于普通人群中 25% 到 10% 的人。有些人不喜欢他们。他们试图调查，
and then they've realized enough people like me that it's probably not a me problem, and they've come to accept the fact. Again, we're not talking about people. who have like the majority of people have problems with them and they're like, I'm just more free if I don't think about it. We need some balance here. Itchiro Kashimi wrote the book, The Courage to be disliked. He says, I think this is the perfect way to just to succinctly tie it all up. The courage to be happy needs to include the courage to be disliked. When you gain that courage, your interpersonal relationships suddenly feel so much lighter. So here is how we're going to do it. Here is how we're going to find that acceptance for the thing and this specific thing
然后他们意识到有足够多的人喜欢我，所以这可能不是我的问题，他们已经接受了这个事实。再说一次，我们不是在谈论那些大多数人都对他们有意见的人，他们会说：“如果我不去想它，我就更自由了。”我们需要一些平衡。岸见一郎写了《被讨厌的勇气》这本书。他说，我认为这是简洁地总结这一切的完美方式：获得幸福的勇气需要包括被讨厌的勇气。当你获得那种勇气时，你的人际关系会突然感觉轻松得多。所以，这就是我们要做的。这就是我们要如何为那件事找到那种接受，以及这个特定的事情
we can't control. Firstly, something for you to just think about every now and again, do you like everybody? Do you? Can you honestly say everybody in the world is your favorite person that you could like, can you think of nobody you don't dislike? No. And is that necessarily their problem, that you don't like them? Also, no. This is a weird exercise, but sometimes I think about the people I don't necessarily like, and I force myself to consider something about them that other people would find positive to remind myself that everybody has a redeeming qualities, including myself, including the people I don't like. And that really gives me a lot of freedom and just accepting that, again, sometimes it's not about me and it's not about them.
我们无法控制。首先，让你时不时思考一下：你喜欢每个人吗？你喜欢吗？你能诚实地说世界上每个人都是你最喜欢的人吗？你能想出没有你不讨厌的人吗？不能。而且你不喜欢他们，这一定是他们的问题吗？也不是。这是一个奇怪的练习，但有时我会想到那些我不一定喜欢的人，我强迫自己考虑他们身上其他人会觉得积极的一面，提醒自己每个人都有可取之处，包括我自己，也包括那些我不喜欢的人。这真的给了我很大的自由，让我接受这一点，再说一次，有时这与我无关，也与他们无关。
Secondly, just like you don't have to change your opinion of those people, despite what may be good about them or not, others don't necessarily have to change their opinion of you because we're not owed an explanation for why somebody does or doesn't approve of us. If you seriously want to be liked by everybody, I think the logic follows that you have to like everybody back. And is that something that you're willing to do? Probably not. I also think it's important to keep in mind the cost of being liked by everybody, and that's like the list we've already given, right? The self-alienation, the somewhat counterintuitive truth that being liked but everyone actually means you have fewer
其次，就像你不必改变对那些人的看法一样，尽管他们身上可能有什么好或不好的地方，别人也不一定非要改变对你的看法，因为我们不需要为别人为什么赞同或不赞同我们而得到解释。如果你真的想被所有人喜欢，我认为逻辑上你必须同样喜欢所有人。那是你愿意做的事情吗？可能不是。我还认为记住被所有人喜欢的代价很重要，那就是我们已经列出的清单，对吧？自我疏离，那种反直觉的真理：被所有人喜欢实际上意味着你拥有更少的
good friendships. The time that you lose, the trust that you lose, especially the time that you spend being obsessive, like, are you willing to pay that cost? Is that worth it to you to spend precious time on earth worrying about those things? Or would you rather invest it in something more fruitful. Thirdly, recognize the way that your fear of being disliked mirrors the things you dislike about yourself and the things that you unconsciously haven't fully accepted yet. Psychologists sometimes refer to this as projection. It's basically a defense mechanism first identified by like Freud in psychodynamic theory where we attribute to others the very traits we feel insecure about within ourselves.
好的友谊。你失去的时间，你失去的信任，尤其是你花在痴迷上的时间，比如，你愿意支付那个代价吗？为了担心这些事情而把宝贵的时间花在地球上，这值得吗？还是你宁愿把它投资在更有成效的事情上？第三，认识到你对被讨厌的恐惧是如何反映出你对自己不喜欢的事情，以及你潜意识里还没有完全接受的事情。心理学家有时称之为投射。这基本上是一种防御机制，最早由弗洛伊德在心理动力学理论中提出，我们将我们对自己感到不安全感的特质归因于他人。
If you're deeply afraid that somebody will find you too much, too quiet, awkward, unlikable, or if you see all those things in them, it's often because on some level, you actually believe that about yourself. Focusing on that root insecurity will remove the need for the approval you crave because you become comfortable with those things maybe being true. Maybe they are true about you. Maybe you are kind of loud or kind of sensitive or maybe not. But whatever the outcome, you're not going to care about it anyways.
如果你非常害怕别人会觉得你太张扬、太安静、笨拙、不可爱，或者如果你在他们身上看到了所有这些特质，那通常是因为在某种程度上，你实际上对自己有这种看法。专注于那个根源性的不安全感将消除你所渴望的认可，因为你变得对这些事情可能是真的感到舒适。也许它们关于你是真的。也许你确实有点吵，或者有点敏感，或者也许不是。但无论结果如何，反正你都不会在乎。
That's just part of who you are. Next, I would also say, change the questions you bring to a social situation to be in your favor. Basically, instead of constantly asking, do they like me, do they think I'm cool, do they think I'm attractive, do they think I'm interesting? Be focused on, and I know it's cliche, but like, do you like them? Especially for dating. Like, do you like them? this first really requires interrogating your fears and anxieties a little bit about why their feelings and opinion why does their opinion matter more than yours where did that come from firstly where did that start
那只是你的一部分。接下来，我还想说，改变你在社交场合提出的问题，使其对你有利。基本上，不要总是问：“他们喜欢我吗？他们觉得我酷吗？他们觉得我有吸引力吗？他们觉得我有趣吗？”要专注于——我知道这很陈词滥调——但比如，你喜欢他们吗？特别是对于约会。比如，你喜欢他们吗？这首先确实需要稍微审视一下你对为什么他们的感受和意见——为什么他们的意见比你的更重要——的恐惧和焦虑，这从哪里来的？首先，它是从哪里开始的？
that your opinion is lower than possibly a complete stranger and link it back to what frightens you the most about somebody not liking you is it that it reminds you of when you felt left out at school and you never wanted to be in that situation again Are you worried that you'll be lonely or that you'll die alone or that you'll be abandoned because of a past experience that's still showing up in your day-to-day life? Can you think of the time or a time where this wound was first opened? And then can you find a way to possibly imagine being okay if that situation were to occur? If the worst-case scenario of rejection, being ostracized, being hated were to occur,
你的意见比一个完全陌生人的意见还要低，并将其与你最害怕别人不喜欢你的原因联系起来。是因为它让你想起你在学校感到被排斥的时候，而你再也不想处于那种境地了吗？你担心你会孤独，或者你会孤独终老，或者因为过去仍然出现在你日常生活中的经历而被抛弃吗？你能想到这个伤口第一次被揭开的时间或时刻吗？然后你能找到一种方法，想象如果这种情况发生，你可能会没关系吗？如果拒绝、被排斥、被憎恨的最坏情况发生，
can you picture yourself being still okay? I think it's important to remind ourselves we are so much more capable and that our terrible feelings and terrible imaginations and hypotheticals never come true in the way we think they will. And you're going to be so much more fulfilled, leaving a social situation, if you have enjoyed yourself rather than if you have constantly curtailed your behavior so that you're enjoyable to others. Because you got to just, it was just easier. It was lighter. You can't feel embarrassed if you don't ask yourself the question of, did I do? anything embarrassing. Like, do you know what I mean? Asking yourself, instead, questions of like,
你能想象自己仍然没关系吗？我认为提醒自己我们有能力得多，而且我们可怕的感受、可怕的想象和假设永远不会像我们想的那样发生，这一点很重要。如果你在离开社交场合时感到享受，而不是为了让别人喜欢你而不断限制自己的行为，你会感到更加满足。因为你必须……这只是更容易。它更轻盈。如果你不问自己“我做了什么令人尴尬的事情吗？”这个问题，你就不会感到尴尬。比如，你知道我的意思吗？相反，问自己诸如
was I genuine? Did I have my own approval? Am I, am I caring about what other people are saying? Am I being truthful? Am I having fun? Shapes the experience so that you are on the lookout for situations and people and moments that are going to create more of that within you. I think it's also worth remembering, and this is probably the biggest thing of all, people are responsible for their own emotions the way that you are responsible for your own. You don't have to manage their discomfort for them. You don't have to manage their negative feelings, their upsets, their annoyances at you for them. Like those are, you don't have to fix every single negative feeling, especially if it's about you. It becomes your responsibility when they bring it up, when they're
“我是真诚的吗？我有自己的认可吗？我在意别人在说什么吗？我是真实的吗？我在享受乐趣吗？”这样的问题，会塑造这种体验，让你去寻找那些会在你内心创造更多这种感觉的情况、人和时刻。我认为也值得记住，这可能是最重要的一点，人们要为自己的情绪负责，就像你要为自己的情绪负责一样。你不必为他们管理他们的不适。你不必为他们管理他们的负面情绪、他们的不安、他们对你的恼火。就像那些……你不必修复每一个负面情绪，特别是如果它是关于你的。当他们提出来时，当他们
honest with you, not when they're being passive aggressive, not when they're trying to manipulate or shift your mood for their benefit. Like they're adults. They can feel annoyed at you, frustrated at you. They cannot like you. And that actually is none of your business. And also, not your responsibility. They're an adult. They should know by now how to regulate feelings about other people that have nothing
对你诚实时，它就成了你的责任，而不是当他们表现得被动攻击时，也不是当他们试图为了自己的利益而操纵或改变你的情绪时。他们是成年人。他们可以对你感到恼火，对你感到沮丧。他们可以不喜欢你。而那实际上与你无关。而且也不是你的责任。他们是成年人。他们现在应该知道如何调节对其他人的感受，而这些感受与那个人
to actually do with that person. A final internal strategy I like to do is also finding a way to separate your worth from your likability. And a very easy way to do this is literally, and a therapist told me about this one, is literally sit down, make a list of all the things that would still be true and would remain true if suddenly the whole world stopped liking you. If the whole world yet tomorrow decided we don't like this person, what anchors you beyond people's opinions? For example, even if the world decided that you were the worst person, you would still be kind to animals,
实际上毫无关系。我喜欢做的最后一个内在策略也是找到一种将你的价值与你的讨喜程度分开的方法。做到这一点的一个非常简单的方法是——一位治疗师告诉过我这个——字面上坐下来，列出如果全世界突然停止喜欢你，仍然会是真的并且会保持真实的所有事情。如果全世界明天决定“我们不喜欢这个人”，除了别人的意见之外，什么能支撑你？例如，即使全世界都认为你是最糟糕的人，你仍然会善待动物，
wouldn't you? You would still be curious about things that you didn't know about. You would still be a creative person regardless of whether people liked you or not. You would still be a good friend. You would still notice the small things. You would still be a great cook. You would still take great care of your body. You would still be a hard worker. You would still think deeply. These things would remain because they're a part of you more than whether somebody likes those parts of you. And the list could go on and on and on. This is basically like, to be fair, it's just a form of positive affirmation. We know from study after study that thinking good things about ourselves is not arrogance, it's self-protection, and it's expansive. Literally, other people's opinions
不是吗？你仍然会对你不知道的事情感到好奇。无论人们是否喜欢你，你仍然是一个有创造力的人。你仍然会是一个好朋友。你仍然会注意到小事。你仍然会是一个很棒的厨师。你仍然会很好地照顾你的身体。你仍然会是一个努力工作的人。你仍然会深入思考。这些事情会保留下来，因为它们是你的一部分，比是否有人喜欢这些部分更重要。清单可以一直列下去。这基本上就像——公平地说——它只是一种积极肯定的形式。我们从一项又一项研究中知道，对自己想好的事情不是傲慢，而是自我保护，而且是扩张性的。字面上，别人的意见
may impact us and can impact us, obviously, that's why we're talking about it. But only if we let them kind of like breach the gates of our self-esteem. Affirmations about our own likability that becomes self-truths. Like I think of them like God. They're like the lookouts that are able to identify somebody else's negative thoughts about us before they reach the gates and are able to discard and get rid of them and realize like those thoughts aren't, that's not one of ours. That shouldn't be here because our thoughts and our belief in our self is stronger. So this, this is an intro guide into how we're going to embrace not being for everybody. And I sincerely hope that you do as early as possible.
可能会影响我们，并且可以影响我们，显然，这就是为什么我们在谈论它。但只有当我们让它们像突破我们自尊的闸门一样时。关于我们自身讨喜程度的肯定，变成了自我真理。就像我把它们看作上帝。它们就像哨兵，能够在别人的负面想法到达闸门之前识别出它们，并能够丢弃和摆脱它们，意识到“那些想法不是我们的。那不应该在这里”，因为我们的思想和我们对自己的信念更强大。所以，这是一个关于我们将如何拥抱“不适合每个人”的入门指南。我真诚地希望你尽早做到。
And listen, like, I'm still figuring it out and I still get really upset anytime I hear a mutual friend or, you know, a friend of a friend doesn't like me. Had that happened the other day and I was, I lost sleep over it. I still at times panicked to people. I shouldn't. I get consumed by me in comment. But I think compared to where I was five years ago, I'm worlds apart from that. And I'm just excited, like genuinely excited for more and more freedom to come with choosing
听着，我还在摸索，每当我听到共同的朋友或者，你知道，朋友的朋友不喜欢我时，我仍然会非常难过。前几天发生了那种事，我为此失眠了。我有时仍然会向人们恐慌。我不应该这样。我会被评论所消耗。但我认为与五年前相比，我与那时已经天差地别了。我只是很兴奋，真正地为即将到来的更多自由感到兴奋，选择
whose opinions of me I get to care about and choosing who I get to be for. Like, genuinely, I don't know if this is something that other people are going through, but the older I get, the more excited I am to be one of the women that I see in their 50s and 60s and 70s who just like give zero fox who say like what they want, wear what they want, eat what they want, do what they want. Those women to me seem like some of the happiest people alive. And I'm sure there's some research that's probably going to confirm that they are. And they also seem to have as well, like the most profound relationships, the most profound
我可以在乎谁对我的看法，并选择我为谁而活。真的，我不知道这是否是其他人正在经历的事情，但我越老，就越兴奋能成为我在 50 多岁、60 多岁和 70 多岁时看到的那些女性之一，她们只是……不在乎，说她们想说的话，穿她们想穿的衣服，吃她们想吃的东西，做她们想做的事。那些女性在我看来似乎是活着的最快乐的人。我相信有一些研究可能会证实这一点。而且她们似乎也拥有，比如，最深刻的关系，最深刻的
friendships, the most profound creativity, because, you know, along the way through trial and error, it seems as if they've learned what we are actively learning now, which is that being for everybody robs you of something you actually probably want more from life, which is to be authentic and to be happy. Not being for everybody gifts that back to you, gifts that self-approved, back to you so that you can live freely. And that's something that I'm just really excited for. I can't wait to give less and less and less fucks about other people's opinions. And I can't wait for that to be a testament that I'm probably doing something very, very right
友谊，最深刻的创造力，因为，你知道，在尝试和错误的过程中，她们似乎已经学会了我们现在正在积极学习的东西，那就是：为了每个人而活会剥夺你实际上可能更想要的东西，那就是真实和快乐。不为每个人而活会把那个礼物还给你，把那种自我认可还给你，这样你就可以自由地生活。这是我真正感到兴奋的事情。我迫不及待地想对别人的意见越来越不在乎。我迫不及待地想让那成为一个证明，证明我可能正在做一件非常、非常正确的事情
with my life, as so many of these, so much of this research has shown us, not being liked by everybody is a litmus test and is the biggest sign that you're probably living life the way that it should be lived. So that is all we have time for today. I want to thank our researcher, Lucy Davidson, for her help with this episode. Make sure, oh my God, are you guys ready? My big list. Make sure you are following us on Instagram.
我的生活，正如许多这些研究向我们展示的那样，不被每个人喜欢是一个试金石，也是你可能正在以应该有的方式生活的最重要标志。所以这就是我们今天所有的时间。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森对本集提供的帮助。确保，天哪，你们准备好了吗？我的大清单。确保你在 Instagram 上关注我们。
Make sure that you have watched a Netflix episode. What's next? Substack. You can send me a DM. You can leave a comment down below. You can send this episode to a friend. There is so much that you can do. And honestly, oh, you can buy my book.
确保你已经观看了 Netflix 的剧集。接下来是什么？Substack。你可以给我发私信。你可以在下面留下评论。你可以把这一集发给朋友。你可以做的事情太多了。老实说，哦，你可以买我的书。
I forgot about that one. All the links are in the description, of course. But please, if you are listening on Spotify, and you are in any of those. countries I mentioned at the beginning, go and check us out on Netflix, just so you can get a sense of the vibe. If you have no idea what I look like as well, because I know some of you don't, now's your opportunity. Off you go, go check it out. As we always end the episode with, be safe, be kind, especially when it comes to social approval, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon.
我忘了那个了。当然，所有链接都在描述中。但是，请，如果你是在 Spotify 上收听，并且你在我开头提到的那些国家，去 Netflix 上看看我们，这样你就能感受到那种氛围。如果你也不知道我长什么样，因为我知道你们有些人不知道，现在是你的机会。去吧，去看看。正如我们总是以这一集结束的那样，注意安全，保持善良，特别是在社会认可方面，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再谈。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It's scary. It's scary. the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence.
那双眼睛里空洞洞的，什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这很可怕。这真的把我吓坏了。醒醒吧。我就是那个亲眼目睹了克雷维特和德皮波行凶的人。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说过，我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Bone Valley》频道中的《魔鬼的采石场》。快乐是必不可少的，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程，走向更快乐的生活。
Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CV. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships,
《Joy 101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》由 CV 呈现。每个人都把我视为足球运动员，但在那之前，我首先是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系、
emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is,
情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于身为人类意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔南德斯，请在 IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一件事不应该像现在这样复杂：移除种族主义雕像。这里有一件事应该比现在容易得多：
getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets.
在原处放置一个新的雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯，《Rebel Spirit》第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，而那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役者的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。每个家庭都有自己的秘密。
But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human.
但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？那不是一个无辜男人的样子。每个人都在对我撒谎，隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Deep Cover: The Family Man》。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证真实。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。